Ich bin nochmal bitte. Guten Tag.
Ich heiße Doktor Ates.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistent Arzt tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen
diesen Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Natürlich.
Bevor Ihre Beschwerden erzählen, benötige ich ein paar Personen Daten.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Helga Schmidt.
Helga Schmidt.
Frau Schmidt, können Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Mein Vorname ist Havi Heinrich, Evi Emil, Elvi Ludwig, Gevi Gustav, Avi Anton.
Mein Nachname ist Schmidt, SCH, Envi Mata, Evi Ida, Devi Dora, Tevi Teodoro.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Schmidt?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
Ich bin 50 Jahre alt, Entschuldigung.
50?
50.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
Ich bin 1,65 Meter groß und wiege 65 Kilogramm.
Ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich seit 3-4 Tagen Schmerzen in der Brust habe.
Seit 3-4 Tagen?
Genau, ungefähr 3-4 Tage.
Wo genau können Sie die Schmerzen?
In der linken Brustwand, Brustseite.
Linkenseite.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer psychischen Skala von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 sehr leicht ist und 10 ist unerträglich.
7 ungefähr.
Ungefähr 7.
Okay.
Haben Sie ein enges Gefühl?
Nein, ich habe Schmerzen.
Schmerzen.
Wie können Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Siehend, zurückhend, stehend?
Das sind so stechende Schmerzen, die in die linke Seite ziehen.
Steckende.
Stechende Schmerzen, die in die linke Seite ziehen.
Linke Seite.
Sie meinen, Sie haben linksseitige Ausstrahlen, oder?
Die Schmerzen ziehen nach links.
Ziehen nach links.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen sie manchmal wieder?
Manchmal stärker.
Aber die sind dauerhaft da, manchmal stärker.
Ich habe Angst, dass ich einen Herzinfarkt habe.
Ich verstehe.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen aushalten bis Ende des Geschwindigkeits?
Oder brauchen Sie sofort eine Medikamenten?
Ich kann sie aushalten.
Okay.
Aber Sie haben kein enges Gefühl oder Todesangst?
Ich verstehe, dass Sie kein enges Gefühl oder Todesangst haben.
Ich habe Schmerzen.
Nur Schmerzen.
Okay.
Frau Schmidt, Sie haben Brustschmerzen.
Richtig.
Ein bisschen stark.
Wir müssen zuerst eine Herzkrankheit ausschließen.
Dann werde ich diese Gespräche unterbrechen und sofort einen EKG schreiben.
Okay.
Und ihren Metallparameter messen.
Danach würden wir dieses Gespräch führen.
Okay.
EKG ist normal, Blutdruck ist auch normal.
Frau Schmidt, können wir weitermachen?
Gerne.
Okay.
Denken Sie, ich habe einen Herzinfarkt?
Nein.
Ihr Metallparameter ist, EKG ist in Ordnung.
In Ordnung.
Dann denke ich, Sie haben keinen akuten Infarkt.
Aber wir müssen weitermachen.
Haben Sie früher eine Beschwerde?
Das erste Mal habe ich so etwas.
Das erste Mal.
Und ich habe Angst, weil mein Vater einen Herzinfarkt gestorben ist.
Vater hat einen Herzinfarkt.
Ich kann Ihnen Angst nachvollziehen.
Wir müssen alle möglichen Untersuchungen durchführen.
Okay.
Dieses Brutschmassen haben Sie erstmals ausgefallen.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser?
Zum Beispiel eine schwere Kiste aufheben?
Wenn ich eine Kiste aufhebe, habe ich Schmerzen.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Gestern und vorgestern habe ich eine Ibuprofen eingenommen.
Ist Ihnen geholfen?
Ja ein bisschen.
Ibuprofen?
Wie viel Milligramm?
600 Milligramm.
Wie häufig?
Einmal?
Einmal habe ich die genommen.
Begleitend haben Sie Atemnot, Luftnot, Hüsten?
Nein, aber wenn die Schmerzen sehr stark sind,
kann ich nicht gut einatmen.
Einatmen besonders?
Okay.
Wenn die Schmerzen da sind, ja.
Haben Sie Herzraten, Atmkulopfen?
Nein, habe ich nicht gespürt.
Haben Sie Schüttelfrostfieber?
Nein, ich fühle mich auch nicht krank.
Haben Sie nachtische Weißfieber?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Ist Ihnen übel oder müssen Sie erbrechen?
Nein, auch nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Haben Sie Hautfarbeveränderung?
Habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie Wasserlassen oder Stuhlfarbeveränderungen bemerkt?
Nein, auch nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie in Ihrer Geschichte bestimmte chronische Erkrankungen?
Ich habe eine Schilddrüsenunterfunktion.
Seit wann leiden Sie?
Ungefähr seit 20 Jahren.
Dagegen nehmen Sie regelmäßig ein Medikament?
Ja, ich nehme ein Schilddrüsenhormon L-Tyroxin.
Wissen Sie, wie viel Milligramm?
25 Mikrogramm.
Okay.
Wie oft nehmen Sie täglich?
Täglich.
Einmal?
Natürlich, nur einmal.
Einmal täglich.
Leiden Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Ich habe keine weiteren Erkrankungen, von denen ich weiß.
Okay.
Nur Schilddrüsenhepofunktionen?
Unterfunktionen.
Würden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ich wurde noch nie operiert.
Noch nie.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Ihr Vater an Herzinfarkt gestorben ist.
Richtig.
Wie ist Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter lebt noch.
Meine Mutter geht es gut.
Lebt und gesund.
Sie hat auch Bluthochdruck.
Sie hat auch Cholesterin-Erhöhungen.
Aber sie ist fit.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder.
Einen Bruder?
Der ist auch gesund.
Okay.
Frau Schmidt, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Früher oder heute?
In der Jugend habe ich ein bisschen geraucht.
So 3-4 Jahre lang.
Dann habe ich aufgehört.
Okay, aufgehört.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ab und an.
Einmal im Monat, zweimal im Monat vielleicht.
Wie trinken Sie?
Bier oder Wein?
Ich trinke meistens Cocktails.
Okay.
Hatten Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Noch nie.
Ich habe noch nie Drogen genommen.
Okay, super.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverschämtheiten bekannt?
Ausstau-Allergie.
Ausstau?
Ausstau.
Wie äußerst nicht?
Mit Niesen, Juckreiz, geröteten Augen, Nasenlaufen.
Haben Sie Unverschämtheiten?
Dagegen Nahrungsmittel zum Beispiel?
Nicht das wirst du nach.
Okay.
Haben Sie vorständig geimpft?
Ich denke schon.
Ich war vor zwei Monaten bei meinem Hausarzt.
Der hat gesagt, alles ist gut.
Okay.
Äh, Ula Schimic, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe keine Kinder.
Okay, was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich arbeite als Putzkraft.
Putzkraft.
Haben Sie Stress beim Arbeiten?
Normal.
Okay.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland oder im Weitland gereist?
Nein.
Ich vermute, dass Sie wechseln werden, oder?
Äh, schon durch.
Bin ich schon durch.
Besuchen Sie...
Es wäre soweit alles okay aktuell.
Okay.
Ich würde vorzeitig in die Wechseljahre kommen.
Mit 45 Jahren.
Wann waren Sie in Ihrem letzten Monatsblutung?
Schon lange her.
Schon lange.
Sie haben keine Probleme beim Frauenheilkunde?
Nein.
Okay.
Ich kontrolliere meine Fragen.
Ich möchte kurz zusammenfassen.
Falls Sie falsch gesagt haben,
dann korrigieren Sie mich.
Sie haben seit 3 bis 4 Tagen Brustschmerzen,
besonders linksseitige Brustschmerzen.
Die Schmerzen sind dauerhaft und drücken oder stehend.
Und beim Belastung zum Beispiel eine schwere Kiste aufheben,
die Schmerzen sind verschlechtert.
Die Schmerzen sind erstmals aufgetreten.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten oder langsam zunehmend?
Plötzlich.
Plötzlich aufgetreten.
Darum nehmen Sie Ibuprofen und helfen bei Ihnen.
Und nehmen Sie regelmäßig L-Troxine.
Richtig.
Haben Sie Aufstoßen?
Aufstoßen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Sodbrennen?
Okay.
Frau Schmidt, ich habe meine Fragen fertig.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder fragen Sie an mich?
Nein, ich hoffe nur, dass ich keinen Herzinfarkt habe,
denn ich bin ein bisschen wängsend.
Ja, Frau Schmidt, ich habe Ihre Angst verstehen.
Aber Sie sind in einem guten Krankenhaus und wir arbeiten im Team.
Wir werden alle möglichen Untersuchungen durchführen
und dann die Ergebnisse vorhanden sind,
werden wir Sie Schritt für Schritt informieren.
Alles klar.
Zuerst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen,
danach Wolle für Labor abnehmen und wieder eine EKG schreiben
und die EKG benennt Fass.
Und dann unterlesen.
Bitte legen Sie auf den Ningen, ich komme gleich.
Alles klar.
Bis bald.
Bis gleich.
Marfene Flanstein,
haben Sie Kribbelgefühl im linken Arm?
Nein.
Beim Kardiologen?
Danke.
Ja.
Haben Sie geschworenen Bein?
Nein.
Sind Sie zum Beispiel länger sitzen oder eine längere Reise gemacht?
Ich habe keine längere Reise oder eine längere Auto-Reise oder Flugreise gehabt.
Ich bin immer in Bewegung.
Ich bin eine Putzfachkraft.
Ich muss viel putzen, ich bin immer in Bewegung.
Warte.
Haben Sie sich in der letzten Zeit verletzt oder haben Sie einen Unfall?
Nein, kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern.
Darf ich?
Bitte?
Haben Sie viel körperliche Belastung bei der Arbeit?
Ja, ich muss putzen.
Haben Sie Bewegungseinschränkungen?
Könnten Sie den Kopf einfach nach links drehen?
Ja, klappt gut.
Kein Problem.
Entschuldigung.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit oder bei Ihnen schon einmal eine Zahneingriff durchgeführt?
Nein.
Hatten Sie früher eine Bandscheibenvorfall?
Nackenbandscheibenvorfall?
Ich bin nicht bekannt, nein.
Wunde im Brustkorb bemerkt?
Nein.
Keine Wunde oder keine Rötungen oder Bläschen oder so habe ich nicht.
Können Sie gut schlafen?
Ja.
Sehr gut.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Krankenhaus?
Nein.
Bleiben Sie sportlich außer Arbeit?
Leider nicht.
Keine Zeit.
Haben Sie einen Auslöser bemerkt vor der Schmerzen?
Besonders?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Besonders Auslöser meine ich.
Zum Beispiel?
Sie haben gesagt, glaube ich, ein starkes etwas aufgehoben.
Genau, wenn ich mich bewege und wenn ich das hochhebe, wenn ich mich belaste,
habe ich diese Schmerzen auf der linken Seite.
Okay.
Strahls die Schmerzen bestimmte Finger oder allgemein die linke?
Nein.
Aber es zieht nach links.
In die linke Seite.
Linksseitig.
Okay, machen wir aus, was ich sprich.
Ja, guten Tag Herr Oberhaus.
Hallo.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen und möchte Ihnen diesen Fallkurs vorstellen.
Hätten Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Natürlich.
Ja, die Patientin heißt Helga Schmidt.
Sie ist 50 Jahre alt.
Sie ist 1,65 Meter groß und 65 Kilogramm schwer.
Die Patientin stellte sich bei uns heute wegen seit 3 bis 4 Tagen bestehender,
dauerhaftige, siehenden Brustschmerzen erst mal aufgefallen, plötzlich aufgetreten und...
Links oder rechts?
Linksseitige.
Linksseitige Brustschmerzen.
Schmerzinterz ist 7 von 10.
Und dann habe ich diese Aufnahme unterbrochen und dann EKG schreiben und Blut für Labor abnehmen.
Danach haben wir ein Aufnahmengespräch weiter gemacht.
Wegen dieser Brustschmerzen, die Patientin nimmt Ibuprofen 600 Migramm eingenommen
und diese Medikamente bei ihm ein bisschen geholfen.
Und Schmerzen bei Belastung verstärken und begleiten.
Belastung?
Zum Beispiel eine Kiste oder Schwerdinge aufheben, dann hat sie Brustschmerzen.
Auch wenn sie treppensteigen oder zügig geht?
Nur bei Belastung hat sie Schmerzen.
Belastung ist ja unterschiedlich.
Belastung, körperliche Belastung mit schwer heben oder schnell laufen, treppensteigen.
Sie hat gesagt, bei Belastung, aber ich habe nicht diesen detaillierten Fragen gestellt.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung werde ich diese Frage stellen.
Diese Schmerzen erstmals aufgetreten.
Begleitend hat sie keine bestimmten Schwerden.
Zum Beispiel Herzrasen, Übelkeit, Emesis, Arithmi oder Erbrechen, Hautfarbeveränderung nicht.
An Vorerkrankungen leidet sie an Hypothyroese seit 20 Jahren.
Dagegen nimmt sie L-Tyroxin 25 Mikrogramm täglich regelmäßig.
Bei den Patienten keine bestimmten Operationen durchgeführt.
In der Familienanalyse ergaben ihre Vater an Myokardinfarktus gestorben.
Ihr Mutter lebt noch und leidet an Arteriellhypertonie und auch an Hypercholesterenämie.
Sie hat einen gesunden Bruder.
In Besuch auf Sozialanamnese ist sie verheiratet und hat keine Kinder.
Sie ist die Postkraft von Beruf.
Sie hat keine bestimmten Stress bei der Arbeit.
In Nesterzeit hat sie keine Gewichtveränderung und den Appetit und Schlaf sind gut.
In der jenekologischen Anamnese ist sie im Wechseljahr.
Ihre letzte Regelblutung ist schon lange hervorragend.
Sie hat Hausstauballergien.
Es äußert sich mit Nissen, Pruritus und Rhinokonjunktivitis mit.
Sie hat keine Unverträglichkeiten.
Impfstatus ist aktuell.
Sie ist nicht Raucher.
Als Jugendlichen versucht sie es ein paar Mal, aber nicht dauerhaft.
Sie trinkt ein oder zwei Mal einen Cocktail beim Promenade.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Das war es alles.
Meine erste Untersuchung beim Anamnese-Gespräch ist,
dass EKG und Vitalparameter stabil sind.
Aber ich denke, dass Anamnese-Gespräche am besten eine Akutt-Coronavirus-Syndrom,
besonders hochwahrscheinlich stabil, anzunehmen.
Sie hat keine Engegefühle.
Sie hat gesagt, sie hat bei Belastungen etwas aufheben.
Vielleicht ist sie bewegungsabhängig.
Haben Sie gefragt, ob das wehtut?
Nein, ich habe nicht gefragt.
Haben Sie gefragt, ob sie Schmerzen hat?
Ja, sie hat gesagt, besonders einatmend Probleme.
Hat sie gesagt?
Ja.
Sie hat gesagt, wenn sie einatmet, hat sie Schmerzen,
dann kann sie nicht mehr weiteratmen.
Ja, richtig.
Sie hat gesagt, wenn sie einatmet, hat sie Schmerzen,
dann kann sie nicht weiteratmen.
Man muss wissen, ob das wehtut, wenn Sie draufdrücken.
Vielleicht haben Sie gefragt, ob Sie einen Infekt hatten.
Hat Sie einen Atemwegskriegeninfekt gehabt?
War Sie krank?
Ein Infekt, Husten, Schnupfen, Erkältung?
Ja, ich habe bei der Vegetativeanalyse viele Fragen gefragt.
Aber begleitend oder vegetativ hat sie keine bestimmten Probleme.
Haben Sie gefragt?
Man muss explizit nachfragen.
Haben Sie vor kurzem einen Infekt gehabt?
Waren Sie erkrankt?
Haben Sie stark gehustet?
Sie hat keine Husten, keine Fieber.
Aktuell nicht, momentan nicht.
Aber vielleicht vor zwei Wochen.
Vielleicht vor einer Woche.
Aber diese Fragen sind nicht relevant in dieser Krankheit.
Nicht relevant?
Aktuell ist Anamnese nur Brustmesseln.
Richtig.
Ein Atmen und Brustmesseln.
Wenn Sie einatmet, hat sie Brustschmerzen.
Wenn sie sich bewegt, schwer hebt, hat sie auch Schmerzen.
Okay.
Sie haben recht, es kann ein Myokadinfekt sein.
Stabile Angina.
Aber normalerweise eine stabile Angina mit engem Gefühl.
Ja, aber nicht 100%
Richtig, genau.
Man muss zuerst einen Myokadinfekt oder eine coronare Herzerkrankung ausschließen.
Richtig, vollkommen richtig.
Aber man sollte hier auch an etwas anderes denken.
Ja.
Normalerweise, wenn Sie eine stabile Angina haben,
haben Sie keine Probleme, wenn Sie einatmen.
Richtig?
Haben Sie keine Schmerzen?
Richtig, aber Einatmenprobleme
während der Brustschmerzen, denke ich.
Nicht mehr so das oder?
Nein, Sie hat ja gesagt,
wenn Sie einatmet, hat Sie Schmerzen,
dann kann Sie nicht mehr weiteratmen.
So hat Sie das gesagt.
Okay.
Also man muss überlegen, natürlich, Sie haben recht.
Ich habe Verdacht auf Angina Pectoris oder stabile Angina, K.A.K.
Alles richtig, vollkommen richtig.
Aber um die Anamnese zu verfeinern,
also eine detaillierte Anamnese,
kann man, weil Ihr EKG ist unauffällig,
EKG muss nicht auffällig sein, muss kein Stemmys sein,
ist richtig.
Aber man muss vielleicht auch an etwas anderes denken.
Vielleicht hat Sie ein Musculoskeletal-Torakalisch-Schmerzen.
Meine Verdacht Diagnose ist Muskelverspannung,
Interkostalneuralgie zum Beispiel.
Genau, kann das sein, es kann auch eine Myokaditis sein,
aber es kann bei Frauen auch eine,
oder bei Männern auch, eine sogenannte Interkostalneuralgie sein.
Ja, ich habe, ja, der Franz Lampisch.
Schonmal gehört, ja, kennen Sie?
Ja.
Genau, Interkostalneuralgie, stechende Schmerzen,
bei Bewegung, nach einem Infekt, beim tiefen Einatmen tritt auch auf.
Ja, natürlich.
Also man muss auch daran denken,
wenn man jetzt alles ausgeschlossen hat,
muss man auch überlegen, später, oder auch in der Unfallambulanz,
es könnte auch eine funktionelle Störung sein,
ein funktioneller Schmerz.
Wichtig ist immer hier zu fragen, meiner Meinung nach,
wenn Sie auf die Stelle draufdrücken,
haben Sie Schmerzen?
Das hat keiner gefragt, dann hätte die Patientin Ja gesagt.
Das muss man fragen,
haben Sie Schmerzen, wenn Sie auf die Stelle draufdrücken?
Haben Sie Schmerzen beim Einatmen?
Haben Sie Schmerzen beim Treppenlaufen hoch?
Oder haben Sie Schmerzen, wenn Sie sich bewegen?
Das muss man auch fragen, haben Sie den Schmerzen,
wenn Sie den Arm nach links bewegen,
wenn Sie den Arm nach links bewegen, nach rechts bewegen?
Das muss man mit dran denken.
Also nicht alles ist eine KHK, also eine stabil angegene Faktorist,
weil Sie haben immer gesagt, bei Belastung, bei Belastung,
Sie haben Recht, aber Belastung ist nicht Belastung.
Es gibt kardiale Belastung,
wenn man Treppen steigt oder einen Berg hochläuft.
Aber es gibt körperliche Belastung,
wenn Sie schwer heben, Muskel anstrengen,
das ist dann wieder was anderes.
Nur dass man dran denkt.
Genau, mit dem Finger kann man das lokalisieren.
Zum Beispiel, wo ist der Schmerz genau?
Die meisten Patienten sagen dann,
ein punktueller Schmerz hier, da, an der Brust.
Zum Beispiel.
Nur als Information.
Gibt es Fragen?
Man denkt immer an einen Myokardinfarkt,
aber nicht immer ist es ein Myokardinfarkt,
nicht immer ist es eine KHK.
Natürlich hat die Patientin eine Familie in der Namese,
Vater ist an Myokardinfarkt verstorben,
man muss einen Myokardinfarkt ausschließen.
Vollkommen richtig.
Man muss alles machen,
V.a. Ultraschall, Troponin, muss man alles machen.
Aber man muss noch detailliert fragen,
was für ein Thorak Schmerz.
Nicht jeder Thorak Schmerz ist eine Angina.
Diese Patientin hat keine Angina.
Sie hat nur thorakale Schmerzen,
punktuell bei Einatmung und Belastung.
Körperliche Belastung, schwer heben oder arm bewegen.
Interkostalneuralgie.
Das ist sehr oft.
In der Notfallaufnahme, in der Haushaltspraxis.
Wenn die Patienten sagen, hier tut es mir weh.
Das zieht nach links oder kommt von links nach vorne.
Immer zwischen den Rippen.
Interkostalneuralgie.
Kann sein, aber sie hat keinen Hausausschlag.
7 ist nicht hoch für diesen Fall?
Ist hoch.
7 ist hoch.
Aber Herr Atec hat gefragt,
haben Sie enge Gefühle?
Mehrmals gefragt, ist gut.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, ich habe Thorak Schmerzen.
Ich habe Brustschmerzen.
Punktuell oder wenn Sie den Arm bewegen,
wenn Sie tief einatmen.
Das hätte man fragen können.
Meiner Meinung nach.
Entschuldigung.
Wir müssen unsere Verdacht
und Differenzialdiagnose relevant mitbeschwerden.
Ich habe eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Richtig.
Auch auf eine Differenzialdiagnose.
Wenn meine Verdachtdiagnose nicht richtig ist,
aber die Differenzialdiagnose besteht,
dann gibt es keine Probleme.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass es ein Problem ist.
Sie haben alles richtig gemacht.
Ich habe nur eine Empfehlung gegeben,
wie man noch detaillierter fragen könnte,
um Differenzialdiagnose zu arbeiten.
Sie haben nichts falsch gemacht.
Alles okay.
Könnte Dauer und Charakter unterschieden?
Dauerhafte Schmerzen.
Sie haben immer Schmerzen dort.
Wenn sie sich bewegt, hat sie mehr Schmerzen.
Aber eine stabile Angina,
wie Herr Atech gefragt hat,
bei Belastung hat man die immer.
Ich glaube, die wichtigste Sache ist der Schmerzcharakter.
Die Lokalisation von Schmerzen.
Zum Beispiel den Lauenpunkt.
Angina konnte nicht genau beschreiben.
Richtig.
Meistens ist Angina drückend.
Ein enger Gefühl, ein drückender Schmerz.
Als wenn jemand drauf sitzt.
Ich wollte mit dem Fall zeigen,
dass wir nicht nur den Fall Myokardinfarkt in den Vordergrund bringen.
Sondern auch, dass es andere Diagnosen häufig gibt.
In der Notaufnahme und in der Hausarztpraxis.
Nicht jeder, der kommt und sagt,
ich habe Brustschmerzen, hat einen Myokardinfarkt.
Man muss daran denken,
wenn man genau fragt,
kann man die Diagnose schon meistens wissen.
Natürlich müssen Sie einen Infarkt ausschließen.
Das ist Pflicht.
Bei Frauen sowieso.
Da kann der Schmerz immer anders sein.
Sie müssen immer vom Schlimmsten ausgehen.
EKG, Tropolin machen.